gérard vespière bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de weert et france alors la
syrie devrait être un sujet majeur des
échanges après la recrudescence des
combats idleb alors que le porte parole
du kremlin a récemment reproché à la
turquie de ne pas assurer le départ de
groupes djihadistes implanté dans cette
ville quelle sera la teneur des échanges
entre les deux présidents au sujet de la
syrie
ou bien c'est un dossier on ne peut plus
compliqué aurait un peu plus chaud parce
que effectivement les premières
escarmouches entre la russie et la
turquie ont été centrées sur cette
région dit la jeunesse pas et il ya déjà
eu donc fin 2015 des bombardements
russes dans la région et la turquie
avait répondu vous en souvenez peut-être
en abattant un avion tueur donc cette
région est vraiment clé dans la
stratégie turque c'est une région qui
est donc avec une un partage de
frontières entre turquie et syrie et
avec donc une communauté de population
en partie turcophone avec maintenant
aussi une circulation de monnaie turc
donc on a là un
implantation en turquie est une carte
importante dans le règlement politique
de la crise tueur de la crise rien de
pardon est donc un c'est pour ça qu'il
est très difficile pour les tubes de
faire un pas en arrière par an parce que
pour eux c'est garder une main si je
puis dire dans les négociations autour
la nouvelle constitution
syrienne par exemple devant produire à
la nouvelle élection politique donc
voyez vous c'est là le coeur du débat
garder des positions militaires pour
influencer les négociations politiques
autre région stratégique pour les deux
pays l afghanistan là encore les deux
hommes devraient en parler on le
rappelle les deux pays qui ont toujours
qu'ils ont toujours un des diplomates à
kaboul quelles sont les préoccupations
communes de des deux pays
je crois qu'il y en a 2 premièrement
c'est effectivement l'accès la libre
circulation auto de l'aéroport il ya
déjà de nombreux mois on parlait de
l'intervention de l'armée turque n'est
ce pas pour un contrôle et
l'aéroport de kaboul donc ceci n'est
toujours pas en place et deuxièmement et
bien effectivement le fait qu'il n'y ait
pas de guerre civile en afghanistan
un pas de conflit interne entre des
résistants et le pouvoir taliban parce
qu' une telle situation
conduirait à des émotions et à des
tensions dans le monde musulman
djihadistes avec des répercussions bien
sûr dans des territoires musulmans en
russie par exemple donc un les les
russes ne veulent absolument pas un
qu'il y ait de tensions à mais à
l'intérieur de l'afghanistan alors une
rencontre on imagine suivi de près par
les états unis puisque la turquie a
conformé a confirmé sa volonté d'acheter
un deuxième lot de missiles s 40 à la
russie l'officialisation à sotchi d'un
tel achat se serait finalement un
nouveau pied n'est à l'otan
or il faut lire les textes avec beaucoup
beaucoup de précaution le spy ne s'agit
pas de volonté il s'agit d'une intention
et nous connaissons la subtilité de
l'habileté de monsieur erdogan et donc
je crois que là il arrive avec un un
demi paquet cadeau de voilages j'ai
l'intention de donc voyez vous il faut
pas être méchant avec moi parce que moi
j'ai l'intention de vous faire plaisir
entre guillemets donc sa fenêtre une cas
de négociations il n'y a ni volonté est
en cours - décision de le faire c'est
simplement une carte supplémentaire dans
le jeu de la négociation entre les deux
pays d'autant que cette chape tayyip
erdogan a encore répété à la tribune de
l'onu soutenir l'entrée de l'ukraine
dans le dans l'otan un sujet de
divergence majeure avec la russie est ce
qu'il pourrait être source de tension
lors de cette rencontre
je crois que le processus d'intégration
de l'ukraine à l'otan est un processus
long donc qui n'est pas forcément
ajouter à la liste des tensions qui
existent déjà entre les deux pays je
pense que la crise autour de l'arménie
de l'azerbaïdjan pour le haut karabakh
et l'avancé un militaire turc en
l'occurrence en azerbaïdjan est
certainement une préoccupation
supérieure pour moscou par rapport à un
des processus ukrainien vers l'otan il y
as au sud du caucase là a vraiment une
préoccupation parce que moscou était
obligé d'augmenter sa présence militaire
en arménie pour faire contrepoids n'est
ce pas donc là on a vraiment un dossier
important entre les deux pays est tel
est le coeur des préoccupations de la
russie justement à ce sujet du haut
karabagh
et bien je pense qu'il s'agit de
désamorcer de trouver une solution in
fine et à cette
délicate
difficulté territoriales il y à une
nécessité effectivement d'avoir des
chemins de communication entre l'arménie
et le territoire du haut karabakh et
donc c'est à ce à quoi l'armée russe est
employé de façon à avoir au moins un
canal de routiers de communication entre
ce territoire et l arménie merci
beaucoup j'en avais ce père pour votre
éclairage ce matin sur rtl france je le
rappelle vous êtes analyste géopolitique
chercheur associé à la faim'' au
fondateur du monde décrypté